The ability to imitate.
It's more of the great evolutionary advantages of our species through imitation.
We learn how to speak a hunt and built,
but there comes a time when imitation fall short and for better or worse,
we are left to plow the soil at her own feet.
What we admire about great minds like Shakespeare play to in Milton,
they said they spoke now what was true of their time,
but what was true to themselves.
They had the courage to follow their own thoughts and their own convictions to
trust in our own intuition and that spontaneous insight which flashes across
each of our minds.
That is genius.
Yet all too often we dismiss these thoughts simply because they are our own.
Instead of owning up to our brilliance,
we give it all away.
In every work of genius we find our own discarded thoughts and with shame,
we must take it from another what we have thought and felt the whole time
American writers,
Ralph Waldo Emerson and Henry David Thoreau where the central figures behind the
transcendentalist movement and the 1830s it was an idealistic philosophy
developed not to oppose the empirical method of science,
but rather to focus on the power of the individual.
Emerson and Thoreau expanded on the system of thought developed by and Manual
Kahn who believe that to understand the nature of reality,
one must first examine the reasoning process which governs the nature of
experience.
One of the key beliefs of transcendentalism is that there's a divinity which
pervades all nature and all humanity as well as a belief in the inherent
goodness which exists in all people.
They believe that society and its institutions,
particularly organized religion and political parties corrupt the purity of the
individual.
They have faith that people are at their best when truly self,
reliant and independent.
The great fear that tears us from the self trust is our apparent obligation to
consistency.
The eyes of the crowd have no means for gauging our personality other than from
our past actions and we are terrified to disappoint them.
We carry along this corpse of past action because it is the only way for us to
find recognition in the eyes of the public to the self reliant individual.
The eyes of the crowd are of no significance.
Speak what you believe now and tomorrow.
Speak.
Could you believe then you are sure to contradict yourself and thus you are sure
to be misunderstood.
Pythagoras was misunderstood and Socrates and Jesus and Galileo and Newton in
every pure and why spirit that has ever been greatness has no need to explain
itself in the present.
It's loyalty is to the future.
It's journey is one of zigs and Zags,
moves and countermoves.
Actions and contradictions are apparently contradictory.
Axar decisions can only truly be examined at the end when the entire corpus of
our life's work can be taken in at once to exhibit originality is what's
happened to our child.
Like nature.
Children are the perfect model of self-reliant behavior because they are too
young to be hesitant and fearful.
They're possessed by a need for self discovery.
The applied their own to the world and have no care for how their actions are
interpreted by those around them.
This stands in sharp contrast with the attitude of cautious adults who because
they are overly concerned with reputation approval and the opinion of others
have great difficulty acting genuine knee or spontaneously.
The worst thing one can be in the crowd is inconsistent,
but it is inconsistency that we find the death of individuality.
Our culture gives us identity,
but at the same time it views our societal role as the totality of who we are.
It protects molds,
constraints and limits us all at the same time.
No matter how much your father,
your mother,
your friends or your culture may try the can never truly insulate you from
reality.
Instead,
we must serve,
rendered,
give incompletely to the temptation of discovery and our curiosity of the
unknown.
It is a path that must be walked alone,
but it requires only one thing to trust in yourself.
Like all the great minds of history.
I'm done.
In doing so,
you will find that child like genius waiting to be discovered.
Okay?
I know we've all had the same experience.
You get home from a long day at work feeling absolutely exhausted.
You know,
you should read a book or do something productive with your time,
but all you want is to collapse and drift to sleep.
Then you remember your audible app and the fact that you have over 180,000
titles right at your fingertips.
You can now drift away as the soothing narration of your favorite books slowly
laws you to sleep.
Keep still,
he orders and slowly here search his top inside me,
like dating it allowed that are striking,
not fun.